Ja, Linus, fünfte Ausgabe.
Hätten wir nie gedacht, oder? Das wir dann hier noch sitzen würden.
Aber du hast nicht dran geglaubt, oder was?
Ich hab's mir nicht vorstellen oder weiß ich nicht. Doch, ist doch schön. Fünfte Ausgabe. Meine fünfte Ausgabe machen.
Es ist wirklich ein Ausbund an Kontinuität.
Ja, bis jetzt sind wir vorbildlich.
Genau und das Ausbund an Kontinuität heißt nach wie vor, Logbuch Netzpolitik, wir begrüßen alle hier zu unserem schlagkräftigen und äh äh kurzweiligen Format,
indem wir Überblick geben wollen über die äh Geschehnisse im Netz politischen Bereich und so auch diese Woche,
und äh ja, die Themen werden euch exklusiv auf den Tisch gelegt von.
Ja, Linus.
Ja, los geht's mit einem kleinen, kurzen Follow-Up. Und zwar äh unser Sopa, der Stop online. Guck mal, ich hab's richtig gesagt. Der Stop online, den wir, glaube ich, in der Folge zwei oder drei schon mal behandelt hatten.
Aber dann.
Den habe ich nicht durchgekriegt.
Schon ein guter Running-Gig auf Twitter geworden.
Äh genau, der ist äh genau. So.
Genau, also bei super äh hat man so den Eindruck, äh gibt's auf jeden Fall hektische Betriebsamkeit rund um diesen Vorschlag.
Genau, denn jetzt hat sich die Business-Software ein
eingemischt in Form eines Blogposts und hat äh darauf hingewiesen, dass sie befürchten, dass dieser Sopa äh wirtschaftlichen Schaden verursachen und Grundrechte verletzen könnte,
Und ähm insbesondere Innovationen hemmen könnte, weil das rechtliche Risiko für kleinere und junge Unternehmen irgendwie zu groß wird. Und haben also quasi gesagt, sie raten von diesem.
Von diesem Act ab.
Wirtschaftliche Auswirkungen. Also man muss vielleicht mal dazu sagen, BSA, Business Software-Alllines, das sind eigentlich die, die so hinter Raubkopien her sind, wie nichts Gutes.
Vor allem Microsoft, aber auch andere Firmen sind dort äh engagiert, ich glaube auch Apple,
und äh bisher kannte man die BSA eigentlich nur so als notorischer Gesetzesverschärfer und dass die sich da jetzt so einmischen was denkst du,
Worauf deutet das hin?
Also es gab den,
Also es soll tatsächlich sogar auf Initiative von Microsoft gewesen sein, wird so kolportiert, dass also hinter dieser hinter dieser hinter diesem Sinneswandel oder diesem Blogpost, der dann da erschien, irgendwie eine,
eine Anstrengung von Microsoft sich verbirgt, nichts Genaueres weiß man nicht, auf einmal gibt's auf jeden Fall diesen Blogpost, wo sie das sagen.
Also die BSA selber offiziell in ihrem Blog.
Ja lass mal schauen, wer das genau war von denen. Ähm mir fällt dann weiß Robert Hollyman,
Hat das da so insbesondere verblockt und dann gab es einen tatsächlich eine richtige Pressemitteilung,
und die ist ja von den Medien, also offiziell von dem Media Contact, von denen rausgegeben worden.
Aber was ist jetzt sozusagen, was was befürchten die?
Warte mal. Ähm ich ich verstehe jetzt deine äh
Deine Frage nicht so wirklich. Also sie gehen ein, die sie befürchten eigentlich, dass eine zu strenges äh intellektual propoty Ride ähm kleinere Unternehmen daran hindert, überhaupt mit Innovationen an den Start zu kommen,
und nicht gleichzeitig von anderen schon direkt aufgefressen zu werden.
Ah, das ist aber eine interessante Sichtweise und das soll ausgerechnet von Microsoft kommen.
So äh ist die Legende.
Mhm. Ich meine, das deutet, also ich weiß nicht, wenn das, wenn das stimmt, deutet das ja äh in gewisser Hinsicht auf einen Sinneswandel hin.
Ja, sie sagen, also sie sagen, sie wollen natürlich äh einen effektiven Kampf weiterhin gegen äh Piraterie haben,
aber äh natürlich muss es irgendwie da darauf geachtet werden,
dass ähm dass die Innovation sich weiter frei entfalten kann und äh Grundrechte nicht verletzt werden. Aber ist jetzt auch wirklich nicht so, als würden sie ja jetzt sagen, okay, wir machen den den vollen Sinneswandel und machen jetzt alles hier nur noch über Pirate,
sondern sie empfehlen den stattdessen lieber den Protect IP Act zu nehmen,
Das war ja das äh der ähnliche ähm Gesetzesvorschlag, der eben in der anderen der beiden US-Kammern,
grade so seiner ähm seiner äh seiner in.
Hart, genau und äh der ist aber eigentlich im Prinzip gleichlauten und verzichtet nur auf ähm so Netzsperren auf IP oder DNS-Ebene. Ansonsten sind hier ähm so gut wie gleich.
Soll ich sagen, jetzt nehmt lieber den.
Das heißt, eigentlich ist jetzt mit Sinneswandel gar nicht so viel äh zu holen, sondern wir wollen da nur die Konkurrenz zwischen diesen beiden Vorschlägen dahingehend.
Man könnte sich eventuell, wenn man jetzt Verschwörungstheoretiker wäre, könnte man auch sagen, dass das jetzt vielleicht einfach irgendwie so ein Stunt ist, dass man sagt, ja, guck mal hier, ne, wir sind
sind gar nicht die Hardliner, sondern wenn's zu krass ist, dann ähm lobbyieren wir sogar dagegen.
Wir können auch anders.
Wir können auch anders, ja, ist ja nicht so, als würden wir nicht darauf äh achten. Überlegt mal, wie wir euch damals vor dem äh Stop Online Piraty Act bewahrt haben,
und äh und euch stattdessen den goldenen, glänzenden Protect IP Act,
vor die Nase lobbyiert haben. Okay, das wäre jetzt so die die. Auf jeden Fall interessante, interessante Töne von der Business-Software,
wie's da weiterläuft, das hat auf jeden Fall, denke ich mal, dazu geführt, wenn selbst die sich da einmischen, damit ist die Debatte sicherlich nicht so zu Ende, sondern bekommt natürlich erstmal ganz neues Feuer erstmal wieder.
Kommen wir vielleicht von den USA wieder nach Europa. Da gab's eine interessante Entscheidung des Europäischen Gerichtshofs.
Ja
und zwar lautet die Entscheidung kurz gefasst, dass eine präventive Überwachung des gesamten Netzverkehrs bei einem Provider ähm nicht mit dem EU-Recht vereinbar ist.
Hintergrund der Geschichte war das zweitausendsieben, glaube ich, die belgische GEMA, könnte man wahrscheinlich ungefähr sagen, dass es das, dass sie dem ungefähr entspricht, die Verwertungsgesellschaft Sabarm,
gegen einen Internetprovider namens Scarlet. Ähm,
erwirkt hatte, dass dieser Internetprovider Urheberrechtsverletzung seiner Kunden durch Fightsharing verhindern muss. Sofern ähm Werke aus diesen Sabam-Repertoire betroffen sind.
Und ähm
Was heißt das für einen Provider? Das heißt, der muss das einfach überwachen, ja? Der muss also irgendwie mit einer mit einer relativ starken ähm Infrastruktur prüfen
handelt es sich irgendwie um diese Werke, gibt's ist das jetzt irgendwie die diese oder jene MP3-Datei kommt vielleicht der Name im kommt der Dateiname vor oder hat diese Datei, hat die einen bestimmten Hashtag gibt's ja verschiedene Möglichkeiten, das irgendwie festzustellen. Auf
Fall mussten sie da den Traffic sehr stark überwachen und wurden dann äh waren durch diesen Gerichtsbeschluss,
Dazu verdonnert, das auch zu machen. Dann haben sie sich an Berufungsgericht gewandt und das Berufungsgericht hat gesagt, ey, komm, wir gehen mal lieber direkt zum Europäischen Gerichtshof.
Design weitergereicht und dann hat der EUGH gesagt, ja, also das betrifft zwar nationales Recht, aber die EU-Vorgaben und die E-Commerce-Richtlinie mit
Haftungsbestimmungen für Provider muss beachtet werden. Das heißt, da hat Belgien nicht freie Hand. Und hat gesagt, äh diese die den Provider, also zur Überwachung, zu,
zwingen, wie es da geschehen ist, äh,
verletzt Grundrechte, verletzt die unternehmerische Freiheit des Providers, ähm verletzt die den Schutz der Privatsphäre der Nutzer und
Insbesondere, was so als kleine Randnotiz war, da haben sich die Datenschützer dann sehr äh großes Interesse daran gehabt, dass ähm diese Privatheit insbesondere deshalb verletzt wird, weil da IP-Adressen gesammelt werden. Und diese IP-Adressen sind personenbezogene Daten.
Mhm. Äh sowas wurde es vom EuGH gewertet. Genau. Aha.
Genau. So wurde von ihnen argumentiert und haben gesagt, deswegen dürfen Internetanbieter keine allgemeinen Überwachungspflichten auffällig werden. Ist ein relativ äh interessantes, mächtiges Urteil, was da gesprochen wurde.
Vor allem auf europäischer Ebene. Ich meine bisher äh lief die ganze Debatte immer so, dass man national irgendwelche Fortschritte erzielt hat, aber dann immer mit Hinweis auf, na ja, aber in Europa äh,
Gibt's ja, ne, sozusagen die bindenden Gesetze und da interessiert den Scheiß äh kein Mensch. Ist das erste Mal, dass ich jetzt eigentlich aus so einer europäischen,
Richtung so ein Sammelsurium finde, weil auch viele andere Argumente, die in den letzten zehn, zwanzig Jahren sich da eigentlich immer wieder drum gedreht haben, wie zum Beispiel unternehmerische, unternehmerische Freiheit, ja, also das ist dem ISP auch, sagen wir mal, überhaupt nicht zuzumuten ist,
für so etwas geradezustehen. Ich denke, das ist auch hier schon lange in der Diskussion gewesen, zumal ich mich immer gewundert habe, dass eigentlich die Wirtschaft sich da nicht noch mehr gewehrt hat,
Also war immer so mein Eindruck, dass sie sich eigentlich da immer haben übern Haufen fahren lassen und haben das ja bei dieser Zensur Geschichte gesehen, ja. Dann haben sie gesagt, ja, Hauptsache ihr lasst uns in Frieden, aber äh wir unterzeichnen da jetzt mal hier den Vertrag, aber äh,
ja
Bleibt uns, bleibt uns vom Leib, aber wir wir tragen das halt jetzt noch mit, wenn man jetzt äh so eine Gesetzgebung oder so eine äh Rechtsprechung an der Stelle äh aufgreift und sagt, naja hier, das ist im Prinzip der klare Hinweis, dass ihr eben,
euch einfach überhaupt nicht reinreden lassen solltet an der Stelle ja?
Dann könnte das interessante Konsequenzen haben, welche unmittelbaren Konsequenzen.
Hat denn das jetzt? Ich meine, heißt das nicht irgendwie auch, dass beschlossenes europäisches äh äh Recht gar nicht gültig ist.
Moment, welches Recht ist nicht, also die das.
Weiß ich nicht. Gibt es nicht. Ähm auf europäischer Ebene Richtlinien, die äh einen zu irgendetwas zwingen wollen in dem Zusammenhang.
Ja, da gibt's ja schon irgendwie diese Idee mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung und ähnlichen Dingen, das gibt's immer. Ich habe,
bin ehrlich gesagt mir auch nicht so ganz klar. Das liegt vor allem daran, dass ich nicht genau weiß, ähm wie da dieser dieser Europaebene, die habe ich selber noch nicht so hundertprozentig verstanden, was da jetzt irgendwie der EUGH ist und das äh
haben sie ja noch das andere Gericht. Ja, das äh warte, was ist das, der ähm,
Sie haben einmal diesen Gerichtshof und dann haben sie noch ein noch ein anderes höchstes Gericht. Und die sind irgendwie unterschiedlich. Und irgendwie komme ich damit selber nicht so ganz ähm klar, was jetzt irgendwie was ist und wo man gegen was klagt.
Ja, es gibt wohl noch das Gericht der Europäischen Union und dem Gericht für den öffentlichen Dienst der Europäischen Union. Das sind so die drei.
So und dann drei sogar, ja.
Hier ist von dem obersten recht sprechenden Organ der Europäischen Union äh die Rede. Also ich meine, wenn irgendetwas relevant ist für eine europäische Gesetzgebung, dann sollte äh das doch auf jeden Fall dazugehören. Und,
Wenn diese Denke jetzt dort sich abzeichnet, ja, dass äh so etwas so differenziert betrachtet wird, dann wird's natürlich spannend.
Das Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung dort äh vielleicht mal auf den Prüfstand käme.
Da kann ich jetzt leider nicht hundertprozentig sagen, ob man dieses Thema irgendwie dahinklagen kann an an diesem gleichen Gerichtshof, weil ich, wie gesagt, diese Strukturen leider nicht verstanden habe,
Bis jetzt nicht ausreichend durchblickt habe, was ja auch ein bisschen darüber zeigt, wie nahe irgendwie oder wie fern dieses,
Europa immer ist, von dem her so ein bisschen, was da immer so kritisiert wird. Natürlich hätte ich mich da mal schlau machen können, aber irgendwie ist es mir nicht ganz gelungen, bis jetzt da wirklich zu verstehen, wie da diese Strukturen sind. Ähm.
Was ich nicht ganz genau weiß, ist, ob man jetzt wirklich mit mit Fordsdatenspeicherung bei dem gleichen,
Gericht irgendwie so gute Chancen hätte, weil irgendwie finde ich diese IP-Adressen Sache, die die landet da so ein bisschen komisch drin, also es passt, da gehört ja erstens nicht zu hundertprozentig mit dazu,
dieser Thema, zu dieser Thema Überwachung und Protokollierung von Internetverkehr, ja, es ist ja eigentlich ein anderes Paar Schuhe und,
Sie haben da auch irgendwie relativ undifferenziert. Ähm,
erwähnt. Also es gibt keine in dem Urteil jetzt keine genaue Ausführung darüber, warum das jetzt personenbezogen ist oder nicht und dann gibt's ja sowieso IP-Adressen personenbezogen sind, ist ja sowieso, dass das große, große Streitthema,
Weil eben die einen sagen, ja, das ist nur der Anschluss. Ähm das heißt ja nur nicht, wer dahinter sitzt und,
ähm andere sagen dann ja, aber doch klar, ist ja eh dann immer der Gleiche, der da den Anschluss hat und ähm dann gibt's dynamischer IP-Adressen und statische IP-Adressen und gleichzeitig irgendwie so ein Provider,
natürlich muss der Provider zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt auch wissen, welche IP er mir gibt. Ja, ist ja ganz klar, sonst kann er ja den Traffic, der zu dieser IP geht, nicht irgendwie an das Kabel,
leiten, was irgendwie an bei mir aus der Wand kommt. Ähm und das ist alles so ein bisschen.
Ein bisschen unklar für mich noch, was was das jetzt zu hundertprozentig heißt. Mhm.
Na gut, aber man, wenn man jetzt einfach mal den Wortlauf äh äh folgt, kann man daraus locker ableiten,
eine Rechtssperrechung, die versucht, ein ISP zu zwingen, Content-Analyse zu betreiben oder auch nur in irgendeiner Form eine Sperrung äh durchzuführen,
so auf Veranlassung äh eines äh Rechteinhabers oder eben eines entsprechenden Generalvertreters für äh Rechte Inhaber scheint auch auf europäischer Ebene gerichtlich nicht durchzukommen.
Zumindest gerade nicht.
Und das könnte glaube ich einigen potenziellen Klägern, die da äh vielleicht bisher noch nicht so viele Chancen gesehen haben, durchaus äh da mehr Mut machen.
Wir werden sehen, wie das ähm wie das weiter verläuft damit. Also ich bin mal,
Ich, wie gesagt, ich bin leider mit diesen mit den Strukturen da nicht ausreichend vertraut, um zu wissen,
wie jetzt zum Beispiel, also sie sagen ja, das geht irgendwie mit den mit den europäischen Gesetzen irgendwie nicht in Einklang, aber was wäre jetzt, wenn es ein europäisches Gesetz gäbe, was genau das,
fair, was genau das macht,
weiß ich nicht genau, wie dann die Situation ist, wo gegen welches Gericht man dann gegen dieses, bei welchem Gericht man dann gegen dieses Gesetz klagen könnte. Das weiß ich einfach nicht hundertprozentig.
Ja, ist die Frage, worauf sie sich eigentlich jetzt konkret beziehen.
Aber da könnten wir vielleicht mal, je nachdem wie das weitergeht, äh kenne ich ein paar Leute, die sich da mit dem Europakram ganz gut auskennen. Die können wir vielleicht mal als Sendungsgast holen zu solch generell vielleicht mal zu Europa, weil das ja ähm,
Immer irgendwie so eine Sache ist mit Europa.
Gute Idee. Können wir uns ja mal für die nächste Woche merken.
Da telefoniere ich mal.
Prima. Dann kommen wir auf äh,
ein noch lokaleren Radius und zwar auf Deutschland. Da gab's gerade einen Parteitag und zwar den Parteitag der Grünen oder wie es so schön heißt, Bündnis neunzig die Grünen,
wo allerlei beschlossen wurde und unter anderem auch ein verhältnismäßig umfangreicher Leitbeschluss zum Thema Netzpolitik.
Ja, sechzehn Seiten von der grünen Partei, die sich so lesen.
Forderungen des Netzes der letzten zehn Jahre.
Es gab irgendwie mal, ich weiß nicht, wann das fast viele Jahre her war, das fand ich einen sehr schönen TAZ-Titel. Da hatte die, da wurde hatten die Grünen irgendwie ein Wahlprogramm vorgestellt für irgendeine Bundestagswahl. Und da war so ein
das war die Zeit für die Tatzen noch, vielleicht machen sie das immer noch so große Bilder immer auf die auf die Titelseite haben, um irgendwie mit der Bild äh zu konkurrieren,
und ähm da war dann so eine so blühende Landschaft und alles so ganz bunt und alle rannten nackt mal so so Bild vom Schlaraffenland und dann so das Wahlprogramm der Grünen. Und da da musste ich jetzt irgendwie in dem Fall dran denken.
Aber jetzt mal den, den äh Netzpolitikern der Grünen ähm muss man natürlich auch zugestehen, dass sie tatsächlich da seit einiger Zeit,
relativ fitte, relativ gute Leute haben. Und die haben, so wurde mir äh zugetragen, da auch sich sehr für anstrengen müssen,
oder haben sehr viel Arbeit geleistet, um dieses Ding
Bei ihrer Bundesdelegiertenkonferenz, so heißt das, ja, ist ja, glaube ich, heißt ja nicht Parteitag, sondern Bundesdelegiertenkonferenz in Kiel war die, äh, um das da,
so als Beschluss einzubringen. Da haben die sich ähm haben die sehr viel Überzeugungsarbeit in ihrer Partei geleistet und ähm.
Denke ich, kann man erstmal so es war auf jeden Fall erstmal anerkennen und da ist mir sowieso immer nur um die Inhalte geht und nicht darum, von wem sie kommen,
auf jeden Fall erstmal sagen, dass ich das ganz ganz schön finde, was da jetzt kommt. Da kann man sich jetzt vielleicht hämisch hinstellen und sagen, na ja, die
das haben wir jetzt nur gemacht, weil's die Piraten gibt. Na ja, wer da ein bisschen die Strukturen kennt, weiß schon, dass die Netzpolitiker von den Grünen schon seit jeher nicht so weit weg waren von den Piraten, also zumindest der, sage ich mal, der Kern der progressiven
Politiker bei den Grünen.
Stammen, letztlich, sagen wir mal der selben Ursuppe.
So so weit würde ich jetzt vielleicht nicht gehen, weil wenn man irgendwie bei die Ursuppe der Piraten, die vermutet der Hörer dann vielleicht doch eher irgendwo auf Pirate Bay oder so. Aber äh sie sitzt sich auf jeden Fall nicht so besonders fair, ne? Und da sind auch einige
ziemlich fähige Leute bei den Grünen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da jetzt Namen nenne oder nicht.
Na klar, ich meine, wenn's da wichtige Namen zu denen gibt, dann nennen sie, damit man die mal kennenlernt.
Ähm ja, also das Konstantin von Notz ist da auf jeden Fall, dass ja der Netz politische Sprecher, der,
innen und netzpolitische Entschuldigung, innen- und netzpolitische Sprecher der Bundestagsfraktion. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein,
Mensch, der, der sich da immer ganz interessant äußert und denke ich auch zum großen Teil mit seinen Mitarbeitern ähm Einfluss,
auf dieses Ding genommen hat. Leider konnte ich seinen Mitarbeiter, den ich auch persönlich kenne, heute nicht erreichen, sonst hätte ich gerne nochmal seine Meinung dazu gehört.
Ja. Kannst ja mal kurz ähm abklappern, also es gibt ein allgemeines Bekenntnis zur Internet äh Freiheit, man äh wendet sich stark gegen Vorratsdatenspeicherung und ähm.
Gegen die Onlinedurchsuchung.
Gegen die Online-Durchführung, Vorratsdatenspeicherung auch so äh,
so, dass es eben bestenfalls diese Quickfries-Variante äh akzeptiert. Dahinter steckt ja die Idee, dass man eben sagt, okay, es ist nachvollziehbar, dass Daten,
strafrechtlich relevant sein können und durchaus auch legitim ist und damit auch legal sein sollte, darauf Zugriff zu erlangen. Nur, dass man eben sie nicht dadurch erhält, dass man sie sowieso schon gespeichert hat und dann guckt man mal nach, sondern dass man äh,
Systeme vorhält,
die eben eher ein Schnellzugriff ermöglichen. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo äh es entsprechenden Richterbescheid gibt und Ermittlungsbehörden dürfen äh jetzt wirklich mal in die Privatsphäre äh eines äh einer Person,
eintauchen, eben weil der Verdacht.
Ausreichend konkret und äh dringlich ist, dass man dann eben die rote Taste drückt und dann geht's halt los mit der Aufzeichnung. Aber das nicht schon mal vorher aufgezeichnet wurde und dann guckt man nur noch nach, was ja die eigentliche Idee der Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist.
Ja, ähm genau. Onlinedurchsuchung kriegt hier auch eine rote Karte. Jetzt Neutralität, äh.
Hochgehalten.
Grundversorgung. Sie reden von Internetgrundversorgung äh von sechs Megabit pro Sekunde, allerdings sagen sie nicht, ob's sich um den Upload oder um den Download handelt.
Ich finde ja meine Hintergrundversorgung sechs Megabit pro Sekunde Upload finde ich ja mal ganz.
Nur so kann man auch den Podcastnachwuchs in Zukunft sicherstellen, aber ich denke, hier ist eher der Download gemeint, finde ich aber gut, dass man das reinschreibt. Finde ich auch gut, dass man das mal,
konkretisiert, zumindest an irgendeiner immer noch diskussionswürdigen Zahl festmacht. Ich glaube, der Telekom wäre drei Megabitter da lieber. Ich glaube, das ist so der.
Das wäre für die, das wäre für wäre in.
Den sie irgendwie immer garantieren können. Trotzdem, ne, ich meine.
Wie geht's eigentlich heutiges Internet.
Ja, ich glaube mittlerweile ist das Problem gelöst.
Genau, also Internetgrundversorgung, da war natürlich dann irgendwie kurzzeitig die Debatte, ähm warum Sex und warum nicht drei oder zehn? Ja, also das das war dann irgendwie ähm,
dann irgendwie gesagt würde bei dem Zeitpunkt zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo tatsächlich so eine Grundversorgung mit sechs MBIT geleistet werden kann, ist das wahrscheinlich lächerlich. Ja, also ich meine, sechs M bit würden mir persönlich jetzt nicht ausreichen. Ich brauche irgendwie, ich brauche ein bisschen mehr.
Nee, mir auch nicht. Aber es gibt Leute, die gehen mit ISDA ins Internet.
Nee, nee, in Deutschland. Heute.
Ja, das sind äh Liebhaber.
Ne, das sind Leute, die kriegen nichts Schnelleres.
Was? Ja klar, das ist äh genau, also da geht's,
genau um diesen Punkt, das ist ja heutzutage wirtschaftlichen Überlegungen unterliegt, wenn meine Farm irgendwie zu weit in der Pampa ist und da irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, ein paar Kilometer Kabel hingerollt werden müssen und zwischendurch nochmal drei Verstärkerstationen
dann sagt die Telekom mir, ach weißt du was, so nimm doch deinen sechsundfünfzig KM, wo der hier über den Analoganschluss, dann hast du doch Internet,
und ähm oder haben ja auch irgendwie angefangen, da in der Pampa zu so diese Leitanschlüsse, ne, dann dann kriegst du halt die die quetschen dann DSL da durch.
Obwohl es eigentlich nicht geht und das wird also, kriegt er also katastrophale Verbindungs äh also katastrophale Bandbreiten, weil es unglaublich viel Paketverluste hat oder was auch immer, aber es ist dann halt leid und ey du hast DSL, so jetzt,
kannst du wenigstens so ein Flatrate-Tarif machen, ja. Was ja mit mit ISDN gab's das ja, glaube ich, auch nicht so wirklich, ne? Oder dann ist zumindest immer eine von deinen zwei Leit,
belegt oder was auch immer
aber dass sie dass dass man ihnen also einen Anreiz schaffen muss irgendwo da in der Pampa auch Internet hinzubringen, auch wenn sich das eventuell niemals lohnt, weil wenn wir irgendwie drei statt drei Verteilerstationen auf dem Weg zu der Farm hinbauen muss, nur damit da noch irgendwie ein Signal ankommt, natürlich kriegst du das mit der Grundgebühr nicht mehr rein.
Darum geht's mit dieser Grundversorgung. Dann wollen sie öffentliche Wählernetze stützen. Können sie machen?
Ja ich bin ja nicht so der Meinung, dass das so unbedingt so eine sich aufdringende Idee ist, es mal etwas zurückhaltend zu formulieren.
Ja, Tim ist äh WLAN-Kritiker. Also.
Der WLAN-Kritiker Tim.
Neuer Vorschlag für Einblendung im Fernsehen.
Den Fehlerfehler zum Aluhut.
Ich habe nix gegen WLAN, ich habe bloß so meine ich meine, ich weiß nicht, wie viel Erfahrung du mit öffentlichen WLAN-Netzen so gesammelt hast, ähm.
WLAN ist Quatsch, WLAN ist dafür gebaut worden, irgendwie mal ähm,
Vielleicht wenn auf genau dieser Farm, ja, dafür, die da irgendwo in der Pampa ist, dafür zu sorgen, dass ich im Wohnzimmer und im Schlafzimmer, äh, ohne Kabel ins Internet kann
wenn ich jetzt hier, ich wohne in Berlin, im Haus, wo irgendwie äh vierzig Parteien drin sind, jeder hat da sein WLAN, da kann man dann das beobachten, was ich immer mit die Luft ist voll,
versuche zu verdeutlichen, Wählern ähm eben grade in dem zwei Komma vier Gigahertzband ist sowieso nicht dafür gedacht, dass der irgendwie großartig viele Sender auf einmal rumstehen
sieht's im Moment noch ganz okay aus. Also wer zu Hause sein äh WLAN-Router auf fünf Gigahertz stellt, der kommt in den Genuss ähm,
einer Rechtsstörungsarmen Verbindung im Moment noch, aber es liegt auch hauptsächlich daran, dass äh fünf Gigahertz halt noch kein Standard ist, den viele Route automatisch machen. Das ändert sich jetzt auch langsam.
Ja, die Telefone haben's noch nicht, also fünf Gigahertz. Aber es ist absolut absehbar, dass es sich da auch relativ schnell äh ähnlich verhalten wird. Aber es ist gar nicht so nur diese äh,
Überlastung. Es sind halt auch viele andere Sachen. Es ist einfach die ganze Manageability von so etwas, ist halt einfach schwierig. Ich glaube einfach, dass wenn Städte sich jetzt entscheiden würden,
also man bildet sich doch mal man stelle sich doch nur mal nur vor, eine Stadt würde wirklich von einer Stadt weiten Abdeckung von WLAN ausgehen,
was das für eine Infrastruktur wäre. Ich meine, das kommt quasi dem Aufbau eines weiteren äh Kunden Telekommunikationsnetzes gleich. Jetzt gibt es natürlich die Idee von Freifunk,
Von äh sich,
autonom ähm organisierenden Gruppen et cetera. Äh wie ist es hier in Berlin auch gibt? Ja und was ja auch lange Zeit,
akute Versorgungsprobleme, insbesondere hier in Berlin-Friedrichshain, da war ja irgendwie über Ewigkeiten DSL nicht zu bekommen,
Da hat das wirklich geholfen, aber ich glaube, dass es einfach langfristig ähm.
Die Technologien, die dafür auch vorgesehen sind, also drei G und LTE in Zukunft ist einfach viel besser abdecken werden. Und.
Ist sicherlich kein Fehler, hier ein generelles Statement zu machen, ist sicherlich auch kein Fehler grundsätzlich auch äh Alternativen Versorgungs äh Projekten, die Unterstützung auszusprechen. Ob das nun ähm das Wichtigste ist.
Also was ja bei Freifunk, das bei Freifunk der spannende Punkt ist ja, wenn ich jetzt mir also Freifunk macht man hauptsächlich dadurch, dass man sich,
auf dem Dach, so einen Mesh Network,
Antenne irgendwie anbringt, die mit den anderen Freifunk Zellen oder mit hauptsächlich einer anderen, möglichst über Richtantenne kommuniziert und dann verwalten sich diese Zellen so ein bisschen untereinander und einige von den Teilnehmern möglichst viele hoffentlich bieten gleichzeitig,
Internet,
für die Leute, die sich in diesem großen WLAN befinden an. Und was da so ein bisschen die Grauzone im Moment ist, wenn man sagt, okay, ich mache jetzt hier Freifunk und lasse die Leute,
mein Internetanschluss,
raus, dann habe ich ja so ein bisschen Haftungsproblematik, ne, wenn die jetzt dann da anfangen, irgendwelche Alben von. Kommen wir später nochmal zu, runterzuladen. Dann kommt der Brief zu mir.
Und das ist äh da sagen die Grünen jetzt in ihrem Amt oder in ihrer Vorlage auch, dass es sein passendes Haftungsrivileg
für geben muss, ja? Dass man aus der Mithaftung, dass die ausgeschlossen wird
Das wiederum ist natürlich schon eine ganz äh ganz interessante, ganz wichtige Sache, wenn dann eben alle Rentner, die die freien WLANs betreiben, durch die der Nachbarsjunge sich äh die die Musik runterlädt, wenn die dann demnächst als Freifunker gelten,
und nicht mehr als äh als Deppen, die ihr WLAN hätten verschlüsseln müssen äh.
Genau, also das das kann ich auch nur unterschreiben. Ich meine, wenn jetzt andere Leute mal mein Telefon benutzen, um damit irgendwelchen äh strafrechtlich relevante Dinge äh zu planen, mich dann jetzt auch gleich haftbar.
Ist äh wirklich so eine Frage. Also insofern auch hier ganz interessanter Vorstoß,
Ich weiß nicht, warum wir es jetzt hier noch komplett durchgehen, wo ich auch noch ein bisschen äh mit der Nase gerumpft habe, ist die Forderung der Straffreiheit von Online-Demonstrationen.
Aber nur wer solange sie händisch sind. Also wenn solange du, solange du nachher auch eine Blase vom ähm F5 oder Apfel Air drücken hast, ähm.
Soll das irgendwie in Ordnung sein, keine Zuhilfenahme von technischen oder illegalen Hilfsmitteln wie Bot Netz.
Ja. Gut, also ich meine, wenn also wenn jemand wirklich nur von Hand eine Seite neu lädt, dann äh sollte ihm das tatsächlich gestattet sein. Kann man jetzt so sagen.
Genau, also sie, sie, sie führen das als zivilen Ungehorsam äh auf, finde ich interessant. Ich weiß nicht, ist ziviler Ungehorsam, eigentlich ausreichend, rechtlich definiert?
Film Juristen, ne.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das eine tatsächliche äh juristische Kategorie ist.
Nach dem Motto, sie haben hier gegen das Gesetz verstoßen, so, nein, ich habe anderes.
Das war, ich habe von meinem Grundrecht auf zivilen Ungehorsam Gebrauch gemacht.
Ja.
Nee, das kommt ja eher aus der, also aus dieser Gandhi-Ecke, oder? Das oder kommt der Begriff nicht sogar daher.
Ja, den Eindruck habe ich auch, aber ich kenne mich da historisch nicht wirklich aus. Na ja, sie fordern auch staatlichen Schutz für Anonymität und Pseudonymität.
Ja, wobei ich nicht weiß, ob ich den Schutz unbedingt vom Staat haben möchte oder nicht, vielleicht doch lieber von ein paar Hackern, die sich da Gedanken drüber gemacht haben.
Na gut, ich denke ist wichtig für so für die Debatte dahingehend, dass ähm man jetzt nicht grundsätzlich,
Anonymität ist gefährlich und böse, ja, sondern dass man auch anerkennt, dass es eben auch sagen wir mal ein,
Bedarf gibt an für Anonymität. Gibt ja genug Fälle oder eben zumindest für Pseudonymität, ne, dass man einfach auch das Recht haben muss
ohne seinen Namen und seine wahre Identität aufzutreten, um sich eben auch einfach selbst zu schützen. Davon gibt's ja genug Beispiele, ne?
Daran vielleicht anpassend direkt, dass sie sagen, also Absage an Post Privacy und sie wollen Datenschutzrecht modernisieren.
Keine Netzsperren und so weiter gegen JUMS-TV
Kritik an der Bezeichnung Kieler Spiele. Also sie haben da wirklich einmal so alles drin, ne?
Kompletten Katalog. Open Data.
Kann ich nur sagen. Ja. Ne, also bin gespannt. Zunächst einmal ist das nichts anderes als ein Parteibeschluss, aber,
Wo du von Anfang schon sagtest, na ja, man könnte ihnen ja vorwerfen, das ist ja nur wegen der Piraten. Ich denke, das ist generell schon zu sehen, umso mehr Parteien sich einfach ein Thema erstmal überhaupt,
nähern und dann eben auch bestimmte Standpunkte unterstützen. Sowas hat auch Auswirkungen auf die CDU. Sowas hat auch Auswirkungen auf alle anderen. Wenn sich die Grünen an der Stelle positionieren und die Piraten das auch noch so sind, klar kann man jetzt sagen, na ja, jetzt,
Kommt ihr endlich mal hier in Wallung? Jetzt wo es die Piraten gibt. Das wird sicherlich auch die eine oder andere Schockwelle durch die Partei äh gesendet haben, um das zu ermöglichen.
Wollte nur damit sein, dass diejenigen, die hinter diesen Sachen, die jetzt da maßgeblich auf, auf dieses Ding hingearbeitet haben, das sind jetzt nicht irgendwelche ähm aufgeschreckten Hühner, sondern das sind Leute, die das seit Jahren so machen.
Schon seit Jahren immer so gefordert hat.
Seit Jahren immer so gefordert haben und das seit Jahren immer so sagen und die haben jetzt offensichtlich ähm
die aufgescheuchten Hühner endlich davon überzeugen können, ja, die jetzt vielleicht in der Partei auf einmal rumgerannt sind konnten, die sagen, so, guck mal hier, weißt du was ich hier seit Jahren gesagt habe, kannst du mir jetzt endlich mal Glauben schenken,
ähm so scheint das da eher gelaufen zu sein. Aber ganz klar so dieser Datenschutzaspekt ist immer noch drin, ne? Das muss man immer so sagen, weil da ist äh,
Konstantin von Notz auch immer sehr,
Noch sehr klare oder was heißt noch sehr klar, der hat da sehr klare Ansichten so, Datenschutz ähm hält er für.
Besonders wichtig. Und will den auch betont haben.
Ja, also die Liste ist wirklich auch noch äh ewig lang, ja, das Lizenzen et cetera, äh Killerspiele, alles findet hier irgendeine äh Erwähnung. Das kann man vielleicht auch sicherlich
nochmal ähm aufgreifen im Detail, wenn die einzelnen Punkte auch noch ein bisschen genauer verstanden sind oder vielleicht kriegen wir auch da mal einen Gesprächspartner zu dem Thema.
Ja, würde ich mich auch mal drum bemühen wollen. Wollen wir mal hoffen, was sich, also wollen wir mal sehen, wie sich was ich jetzt aus diesem Papier ist ja geduldig. Monitor Tinte noch mehr. Wollen wir mal schauen, wie sich das jetzt so.
Ja, kommen wir vielleicht ähm so als vorletztes Thema, ich weiß nicht, äh hier von der äh von der von der für eine Möglichkeit der Zukunft so realen Überwachungsrealität.
Ähm Funkzellenüberwachung in Dresden gab's ja bei dieser Nazidemonstration
das war ja relativ groß in den Medien, machen wir auch nochmal einen Link dazu und da hat die Landtagsabgeordnete NRW Landtagsabgeordnete Anna Konraz
ähm eine kleine Anfrage eingereicht
und hat sich da mal so ein bisschen erkundigt, wie wird denn, wie oft denn von diesem äh Funkzellenauswertung Gebrauch gemacht wird und wie oft so stille SMS versendet werden. Es steht der SMS ist eine Diagnose, SMS, die so an das an ein Handy geschickt wird. Dieses Handy kriegt diese SMS, bestätigt den Empfang,
und macht gar nix. Äh eine quasi in Standard in GSM definierte Funktionalität, die den schönen,
Vorteil hat dadurch, dass sie, dass das ist, dass das Handy den Empfang fitiert, muss es sich einmal bei seinem Funkmasten melden und dadurch weiß ich dann, wo sich dieses Handy befindet.
Aber das weiß man ja eigentlich auch schon vorher. Ich meine, es ist ja sowieso immer eingebucht, sonst könnte es ja nicht klingeln, wenn's angerufen wird.
Ich glaube, der eigentliche Kniff ist, dass dass es an der Stelle quasi eine tatsächliche Kommunikation ist, die an dieser Stelle äh stattfindet und von daher als Überwachungs äh fähig gilt.
Das kann natürlich sogar, also das äh das kann es, wahrscheinlich ist das der Trick dahinter, ne? Man könnte natürlich auch einfach.
Ja, weil die Position hier haben die Netze sowieso. Ich meine, du läufst da durch die Zelle, du buchst dich da ein, du bist da. Also es ist diese Information liegt vor, aber sie äh darf nicht generiert werden.
Ist das das, also ist das tatsächlich so, dass sie, dass sie tatsächlich so stark orten? Ich will mir da gar nicht so.
Sie orten dann auf jeden Fall jetzt durch diese SMS nicht genauer,
Weil du bist halt nur eingebucht, eine richtige Ortung im Sinne von Geokoordinate kannst du ohnehin nur durch so eine Triangulation, also durch das Zusammenziehen verschiedener äh Messungen von benachbarten,
Basisstationen erhalten. Dadurch, dass äh du ja ohnehin nicht nur in der einen,
Zelle eingebucht bist, sondern ja von den anderen auch gesehen wirst, aber du eben der anderen zugewiesen wirst, weil du da eben das stärkste Signal hast, beziehungsweise das Telefon äh diesen Schritt äh vornimmt.
Also was sie äh der Innenminister spricht selber, also hier der NRW Innenminister Ralf Jäger spricht selber davon, dass diese stille SMS einen Ortungsimpuls ist. Also sie wird auf jeden Fall zur zum.
Also sie wird zur Ortung genutzt. Ich frage mich jetzt, wenn.
Ja, weil's in dem Moment Verbindungsdaten erzeugt. Das ist der Punkt. Das ist nicht halt einfach nur die Bewegung im Netz, sondern es ist sozusagen offiziell eine Verbindungsdatenvorfall und der kann dann eben als solcher auch abgegriffen werden.
Ja
Das scheint es so zu sein. Auf jeden Fall, das haben sie, Anfrage war, also habt ihr das, wie oft habt ihr das denn so gemacht? Und dann kommt die Antwort von dem Innenminister und sagt, ja, ähm,
So grundsätzlich haben wir fünftausendzweihundertsechsundsiebzig Mobilfunkanschlüsse überwacht. Ähm,
Und bei zweitausendsechshundertvierundvierzig davon haben wir auch diese Ortungsimpulse versandt. Und jetzt können wir aber je nachdem, dass die machen wir ja in,
manchmal entweder schickt man vielleicht ganz viele, mehrere hundert oder manchmal auch nur so einen die Woche. Auf jeden Fall insgesamt im Jahr zweitausendzehn haben wir in NRW zweihundertfünfundfünfzigtausend,
siebenhundertvierundachtzig solche stille stille SMS Ortungsimpulse versand.
Eine SMS, wissen wir ja, neunzehn Cent.
Ja, das sind so sechshundertachtzig siebenundachtzig pro Tag.
Es ist also eine ganze Menge und das ist nur ein Bundesland, zwar das Bevölkerungsstärkste in Deutschland mit achtzehn Millionen, glaube ich, NRW.
Kann man wahrscheinlich also der der Schluss, das jetzt hochzurechnen auf äh alle Bundesbürger ist sicherlich nicht äh hundertprozentig äh reliabel oder valide, aber wenn man so sieht, in einem Bundesland allein,
über eine Viertelmillion ist schon mal,
interessant für so ein Thema, was irgendwie immer so stille SMS, das hörte man höchstens mal irgendwie von Frank Rieger und Konstanze kurz, dass es da die stille SMS gibt und das war dann in diesem
Buch und dann ja von diesen Radikaldatenschützern, stille SMS oder so, dass da dieses Thema war irgendwie vorher nicht so.
Ja. Ne, es findet statt. Es ist äh es ist äh.
Relativ offen.
Es ist einfach Praxis, ja.
Gab's da noch diese gab's natürlich dann die Presse äh Mitteilung von Anna Konrads und dem André Hunko, auch von den Linken, die dann äh,
sagen, ja, muss irgendwie bundesweit wollen sie jetzt bundesweit wissen, was da los war und wie viele da so verschickt wurden. Interessant war sogar zweitausendneun waren das sogar dreihundertzwanzigtausend,
Also ähm.
Lässt nach.
Ja. Dann äh kommen wir zu unserem äh Abschlussparty Thema.
Ja, das war ja das ja eher nur so eine kleine kleine Randmeldung.
Irgendwie in den Medien und im im Facebook oder was hat sich da gegen Abmahnanwälte ähm ausgesprochen, hat da wie gesagt, sind alles irgendwie Abzieher und was die mit ihrer Abmahnkram verdienen, da kriegen wir gar keinen, kriegen wir keinen Cent von.
Und ähm hat dann irgendwie gesagt, man soll Musik von Leuten, die man mag, kaufen und von Leuten
die ohne Herzblut Musik machen soll man das runterladen aber nicht überwischt soll man irgendwo anders machen und die sind alle doof,
sagt Jan Delay.
Ja und dann hat er irgendwie eine Menge äh Wirbel damit gemacht und äh war dann, glaube ich, von dem Wirbel selber ein bisschen überrascht und kriegte dann auch von seinem äh
Label äh mitgeteilt, dass er ja auch selbst in seinen regelmäßigen Überweisungen auch
Gelder davon äh hat, was ihnen dann wohl überrascht habe und der dann auch zugesagt hat, dass er das Geld jetzt weiterreichen möchte, spenden. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau
was er damit tun will.
Also ich fand das insbesondere deswegen witzig, weil ich nur eine Person kenne, die jemals abgemahnt wurde. Und äh diese Person wurde,
wegen eines abgemahnt in einer, in einer WG, ja? Also die die der hatte hat die Person selber nicht runtergeladen, kam ja auch für verbürgen, die hört diese Musik nicht. Aber wurde von,
abgemahnt. Und diese Person war auch mäßig erheitert äh dann der ausgerichtet von Jan Delay.
Er hat dann schon so überlegt, ob er so schreibt, ey yo, Jan, korrekt so, ne, wie sieht's aus so hier äh zweihundertsiebzig Euro hast du die Verkürzung?
Naja gut, aber er meint ja, so äh das also er meinte zumindest zu dem Zeitpunkt, dass ihm das ja gar nicht so zugute kommen würde, sondern ja vor allem äh äh den Anwälten, was sicherlich richtig ist.
Stimmt natürlich klar, diese, also Teil dieser Meinung sind insbesondere diese Abmahngebühren und die gehen natürlich nicht an äh Janila. Die die richten sich ja nur nach dem Streitwert und,
Damit ist das oder oder ich weiß nicht, richten die sie nach dem Streitwert oder nach dem Standard Arbeitsaufwand? Oder ist, glaube ich, Arbeitsaufwand gewichtet, mal Streitwert oder was auch immer.
Keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung. So und da werden wir mal wieder festgestellt haben, dass wir auch bei vielen Bereichen einfach keine Ahnung haben, würde ich sagen.
Oh je.
Die Sendung dann auch ab. Da sind wir noch unter zweiundvierzig Minuten. Ist gut.
Haben wir wenigstens das geschafft, keine Ahnung, aber unter zweiundvierzig Minuten. Das wäre ein schöner Sendungstipp.
Ja, genau. Meinst, wir sollten jetzt auch lustige Sendungstitel einfallen?
Weiß ich nicht. Weil bei dieser Sendung müssen wir uns das mal vielleicht überlegen.
Sonst werden die Titel einfach zu lang. Na gut, dann sagen wir tschüss. Auf Wiederhören. Bis bald.
Auf Wiederhören.